lui sufi hai rubato un corno blu per me
ruberei un'intera orchestra per the
hallway sufi
merchandise se c'è un argomento che
costantemente tirate fuori quando si
parla del mio canale you tube ma i video
ma il secondo argomento che viene sempre
fuori ma dove posso comprare la tazza
dello show o la maglietta delle
recensioni o lo sfondo di mostarda da
nessuna parte perché se c'è qualcosa che
mi turba purtroppo è il pensiero che
qualcuno stia camminando per le strade
della sua città natale con la mia faccia
gigante sul petto e non mi è mai
piaciuta questa cosa qua infatti quando
ne parlo magari con un collega la prima
cosa che mi viene detta e perché ove i
soldi non che non ci abbia provato nel
corso degli anni ma tutto quello che ho
creato era sempre staccato d'aiuto b non
era mai la maglietta di yotobi non erano
mai le mutande con la faccia di youtube
ma era sempre qualcosa parallelo quindi
una maglietta delle recensioni o la
maglietta di qualcosa che ho fatto nel
canale di gaming si parla di tantissimi
anni fa voi non avete idea della merda
che avevo creato e sembra che facendo
così io sia contro al merchandise degli
influencer ma non è così anzi vi dirò di
più probabilmente io almeno un pezzo di
merchandise per ogni singolo you tube
che sia libro maglietto film fiero di
loro come se fossi il loro babbo che li
ha visti finalmente segnare il loro
primo gol nella squadra dei pulcini il
mio cervello non è solo contento per
loro ma è anche molto contrariato forse
perché sono pazzo
sicuramente però è anche come è un po
una sorta di variante dell'over view
effect che hanno gli astronauti quando
guardano per la prima volta la terra
dallo spazio provano questa sensazione
di maestosità infinita ma anche
alienante mente distaccante ed è molto
[ __ ] come cosa è per me è l'esatto
contrario ci sono io zero g nell
international space station che fluttua
senza sapere cosa fare perché non sono
un astronauta nei corridoi della
stazione spaziale e guardo da un oblò in
me contro te io non so se voi abbiate la
reale idea di dove si spinge il
merchandise dei me contro te voi siete
in giro per centri commerciali durante
il periodo natalizio e trovate nel
reparto di libri
il libro degli autogol o ancora più
specifico andate nel negozio di dolci e
trovate il panettone deve milanesi in
brutti ancora più specifico siete nel
reparto della tuti in mezzo ai bradipi
trovate chiara ferragni
tutte queste cose che vi ho appena
descritto sono zero rispetto a lui e
sophie diciamo subito che io lui e
sophie li amo e secondo me denunciatemi
denunciatemi sono i migliori
youtube youtube italia mi dispiace
lorenzo mi dispiace adrian non mi
dispiace per niente
alessandro ma se c'è uno youtuber che ha
capito perfettamente che direzione
prendere con il canale perché ha
compreso quale sia realmente il pubblico
che ha un certo punto li ha seguiti sono
loro due e stanno cavalcando un'onda che
ripeto voi non avete idea di quanto sia
alta tutto quello che vedrete l'ho
fotografato e filmato io non vi nego che
adoro andare nel reparto giocattoli di
centri commerciali
un po perché adori giocattoli forse
perché crescendo non ne ho avuti
tantissimi come avrei voluto quindi il
mio cervello adesso dice te li puoi
permettere comprarli tutti per cortesia
un po perché mi fa ridere scoprire tutti
i giochi di parole che le aziende
birichine si inventano per vendere
questi giocattoli e pierino il
porcospino sochi doggy gastone testone
pepito serpente bandito stendino
birichino colosso molla l'osso è il mio
preferito in assoluto
8 il maya lotto che fa il botto poi giro
l'angolo e vedo questo un paradiso
terrestre lontano dal mio target a prima
occhiata con il design che hanno
sembrano quasi tutti lo stesso gioco ma
se noi zoomiamo un pochino possiamo
trovare una cornucopia di giocattoli il
créa pennarelli lolli paul la tnt
challenge la pop corn challenge e le
bambole gli orologi
qui per esempio ci sono le confezioni
delle candy surprise nole tipo le
caramelle tutti i gusti più uno però se
guardate bene la ripresa c'è anche una
confezione di pasta modellabile e come
gli ovetti kinder un bambino su cinque
finisce in ospedale
monopoly me contro tel
se c'è uno youtube nella sua vita che
dovrebbe diventare una pedina del
monopoly quello sono io
[Musica]
quanti cazzo di libri hanno fatto ho
comprato libro sofia e la bestia
in questo libro sophie viene rapita da
una bestia che ipotizzo sia il povero
lui sofia è preoccupata ma la bestia si
comporta in modo gentile
i giorni passano sophie non si sente
trattata come una prigioniera e comincia
a provare simpatia per la bestia
questo è un libro sulla sindrome di
stoccolma o se volete andare molto più
sul banale lui e sophie eruzioni
sorprendente ed ovviamente anche loro
vanno nello specifico e più si va nello
specifico più mi diverto e infatti loro
hanno fatto dei lui e sophie robottini
che tu costruisci e poi ci puoi mettere
una tua fotografia dentro quale cazzo di
bambino fa le foto e le stampa tra
e poi ci sono ombrelli un sacco di
ombrelli perché ci sono così tanti
ombrelli e sono molto strani perché mi
immagino il mio rivolto su un ombrello
tanto mi è capitato di trovare cercando
gli ombrelli dei miei contro te un
ombrello molto particolare io ora vi
leggo una delle recensioni ad una stella
purtroppo il prodotto è di qualità
scadente
avete presente le buste di plastica è
quasi uguale molto fine e molto più
piccolo di come descritto per mia figlia
di 6 anni praticamente inutile forse per
le barbie ecco questo venditore per
vendere l'ombrello ha usato come
immagine un pacco di preservativi
ringraziando iddio forse se ne sono
accorti hanno rimosso questo articolo ma
ora avendo in mente l'immagine dei
preservativi
rileggete la recensione avete presente
le buste di plastica è quasi uguale
molto fine e molto più piccolo di come
descritto per mia figlia di sei anni è
praticamente inutile forse per le barbie
tremenda questa cosa qua però non è
colpa mia
il mondo
che funziona così non è non è solo il
mio cervello giuro ed è molto probabile
che la mia sia più nvidia che altro
perché è vero che loro hanno un target
molto diverso ma io comunque non
riuscirei a vedere la gente con il mio
merchandise per strada o in casa c'è
qualcosa che mi frena sia dal fare un
fracco di soldi perché per esempio è
vero che io ho fatto la maglietta per il
video di vanna marchi
ma come ho detto all'inizio eppure
ironia quella e voi avete il cervello
spappolato per averla comprata quella
maglietta vi immaginereste mai un mio
merchandise dopo 13 anni di youtube lo
sapete cosa regalare i vostri amici per
natale il calendario dell'avvento delle
ciò con karim usa non iscrive avete un
bar in casa i sottobicchieri del
beviamoci su era questa la tua carta
delle show con karim usa un calendario
da ufficio con la stessa fotografia ogni
mese dovete fare delle riunioni di
lavoro con la cover delle ciò con karim
usa così potete farvi picchiare al
lavoro tra un po c'è san valentino e che
cosa vuoi regalare la tua anima gemella
se non un globo di cuoricini delle ciò
con karim usa
[Applauso]